はじめ）明るい　いや俺もでも明るいよね？
たなっち）明るいです
はじめ）めっぽう明るいよね
たなっち）うんめっぽう明るい
(たなっちの髪色！？！？)
はじめ）ほらもうこれでき…
たなっち）ふはははははｗｗやばｗ
はじめ）こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
たなっち）こんにちは　たなっちです
はじめ）たなっちさん
たなっち）はい
はじめ）前回変な煙のドッキリしかけたの覚えてますか？
はじめ）体に健康な煙が
たなっち）あぁ
はじめ）素直にどう思いました？
たなっち）いやあれですよね？
はじめ）ううぅぅぅ(´；ω；`)
たなっち）ｗｗ
はじめ）あれ結構たくさんやったのに
はじめ）やっぱ健康だからか知んないんですけど
はじめ）煙の量がすごい少なくて
はじめ）あの僕はかなり裏切られました
はじめ）“おいこれクソつまんねぇーな“
って思って編集してたんでこうやって
はじめ）っていうのを踏まえて
はじめ）もうあれの物量をそもそも増やそうということで
はじめ）でなんかいろんな要因があったと思うんすよあれ
はじめ）そもそも部屋が大きいから煙があんまり蔓延しなかったっていう理由
はじめ）ってこれがそもそも1個しかなかったから煙が自体が少なかったっていう理由
はじめ）まぁ色んな理由あって
はじめ）まぁ正直クソしょうもなくなっちゃったんで
はじめ）今回はそれを4倍にして　なん、何個だこれ？
はじめ）前回10個だったんですけど
はじめ）今回は4倍の40個でやっていきたいと思います
はじめ）もう使い方もこういう感じで
はじめ）ドラマの撮影とかでスモーク炊きたい時に
使うってやつです
はじめ）俺はもう完璧な作戦を考えた
はじめ）部屋が狭ければいいんすよ
はじめ）部屋が狭ければ煙が篭るんで
たなっち）なるほど
はじめ）はい
はじめ）はははｗそうだろう
たなっち）まったく
はじめ）はっはっは！そればかりはわ、分かんねぇんだよな俺も
はじめ）あっはは！そうか教えてやろう
はじめ）今ですねだいちくんが買い出しに行ってて
はじめ）車を使ってます
たなっち）うん
はじめ）仕掛ける用の車　で、その車に乗って今から帰ってくるんで
はじめ）帰ってきたらもちろんここにくると
はじめ）車にもう頑張って俺たちでこれを仕掛けに行って
はじめ）もう全部燃やして煙出しまくって
たなっち）うん
はじめ）車の中もうモクモクモックックーにすると
たなっち）あはｗ
はじめ）そこで「だいちくんごめん車に忘れ物したからちょっと取って来てやー」みたいな感じで言って
たなっち）うんうん
はじめ）で「あーい」って取りに来たら
はじめ）車の中が大変　もう
たなっち）モクモクモックックー？
はじめ）モクモクモックックーだよｗ
はじめ）モクモク木曜日でさ
はじめ）っていうドッキリをしたいと思います
たなっち）はい
はじめ）おそらく超慌てます
はっはっはっは！
はじめ）前回のリベンジも
はじめ）煙の量はかなりやばいし車だと篭ると思うんで
はじめ）相当な迫力になると思います
はじめ）では帰ってくるまで待ちましょう！
おっほっほっほ！
はじめ）いきまーす
たなっち）はい
はじめ）ごめんちょっとコンビニ行って来まーす
だいち）はい
たなっち）だって「鍵はー？」つって上取りに行ったのに
たなっち）車の鍵忘れるってやばいっすよ
はじめ）車にカメラを仕掛けちゃいます
はじめ）へっへっへ
はじめ）うわっけむけむ〜
はじめ）煙がすごいんですぐ車の中に入れましょう
はじめ）いきます
はじめ）やばいやばい
はじめ）たなっち
はじめ）がちやばい　やばい　閉まんない
たなっち）やばい
はじめ）早く早く
はじめ）早く早く早く早く
たなっち）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）早く待ってやばいやばい事件事件事件ｗ
たなっち）ははははｗｗｗ
はじめ）大丈夫大丈夫耐えてる耐えてる
はじめ）だいちくーんちょっと来てー
だいち）え？なになに？え？え？なになになに
だいち）え！？なに？？？？
はじめ）はっはっはｗｗｗｗｗ
だいち）え？待ってやばくない？
だいち）なに？なになに！？なにこれ？
だいち）え？待ってなんかなんかねぇ
はじめ）ｗｗｗｗ
だいち）なに？
だいち）あっ、そういうことか
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
だいち）全然気づかなくて開けた瞬間煙出てきて
はじめ）え？え？え？なに？なに？なに？
だいち･たなっち）ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）健康な煙なんで大丈夫
だいち）あ、吸っても害ない
はじめ）吸ってみよう
だいち）うわっすげーすげー
だいち）ゲホッゲホゲホ
だいち）ゲホッ
はじめ）うわー待って
はじめ）うーわうーわ　うわっ待ってすごい
だいち）ゲッホ
だいち）待って息できない
たなっち）なんも見えない
はじめ）いやでも…
だいち）ゲホ
はじめ）ダメだ無理だなんか体に良くねー
はじめ）うわすごいこっからも面白いんだけど
だいち･たなっち）ｗｗｗｗｗ
たなっち）ここから漏れてんすね
はじめ）ここから漏れてんだねもうｗ